a gang war gun trafficking and a man
wanted right here in southern Nevada as
for series Manhunt Monday 8 news now
investigator Vanessa Murphy brings you
the story of Davion Rowe and why Law
Enforcement wants to know if you've seen
him
it's described as a gun trafficking
scheme and court documents obtained by
the eight news now investigators Davion
Rowe is accused of buying 40 guns for
family members in the notorious Crips
Street gank and now he's on the run it's
our belief that through his family ties
and friends here in the Las Vegas area
and in California he's been able to
evade law enforcement thus far Raymundo
Venegas is a supervisory Deputy U.S
Marshal part of a team to track down Row
the case began in 2021 when
investigators say they were alerted Roe
bought 40 guns from grabagun.com paying
nearly 28 thousand dollars within 60
days he filled out a form saying the
guns would be his but investigators say
he lied they uncovered text messages
between row and a known felon with a
violent past he tells Roe what to buy
agrees to pay and that same Phelan was
Withrow when he picked up most of the
weapons from this gun shop that's also
when the ATS says law enforcement
intercepted before those guns could make
it to the streets how serious were these
allegations these allegations are very
serious while he didn't go out and
commit any crimes that we were aware of
with these firearms
these these Firearms had they been
distributed or if some of the more
distributed could have led to other
murders or gun violence across the
California Las Vegas area according to
this wanted poster those guns could have
been used in a violent feud between the
Crips and another game prosecutors say
when Roe asked how he could pay that
nearly 28 grand he said he was recently
fired from McDonald's but quote various
females pay him for relationships while
the case against his two co-defendants
moved forward Roe is yet to have his day
in court can never be a good look in
front of a judge if someone's not
turning themselves in right I would
agree with that I'm not the judge but it
definitely goes a long way when somebody
turns himself in he says this is a photo
of Roe from Canyon Springs High School
in North Las Vegas but today row is 23
years old he also has some nicknames
Dave and day boy the U.S Marshals will
continue to search for Roe while also
asking anyone who may have seen him to
let them know Vanessa Murphy 8 News Now